Aquaman since 2018 out on a high note
this has arguably been the best year for
comic book movies ever and the film
possesses an ending and post credit
scene which both have a lot to unpack
from them throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the movie and the post
credits scene as well as where I think
the franchise will go in the future
there will be heavy spoilers and this is
definitely a film that I recommend that
everyone sees without having the events
in it room for them so you have been
warned for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to the film opens on Tom curry a
lighthouse keeper that discovers Queen
atlanna
washed upon the shore atlanna fled from
Atlantis after she was almost forced to
marry a man she didn't love and her and
Tom fall for one another and have a
child named Arthur one day the forces of
Atlantis arrive at the lighthouse and
attempt to take out Lana in while she
defeats them she realizes that Atlantis
will forever put her and her family in
danger so returns to the sunken sea Tom
still walks at the end of his lighthouse
Jay every day but she never returns an
author grows up and heads out into the
world
the rest of the film picks up after the
events of Justice League and loosely
follows the Justice League new 52
graphic novel throne of Atlantis in that
Atlantis begins a war with the surface
world after a naval attack and this
movie too follows that narrative similar
to that story Atlantis is now led by ohm
who is revealed to be Aquaman's
half-brother we discover that all that a
false flag attack after hiring Black
Manta to steal a submarine earlier in
the film Manta was stopped by Aquaman
and his father was killed during the
face off after Aquaman refused to save
him this builds a rivalry between the
two and definitely feels a lot of mantas
motives fearing that the war will kill
billions mera returns to the surface in
order to get Arthur to return to
Atlantis defeat his brother and reclaim
the throne Arthur hate Atlantis as he
learned that his mother was sent to the
trench and killed for bearing him but
agrees to return after a tidal wave
destroys the town that he lives in
however when he arrives at the city
Arthur is arrested and all challenges
him to combat
in the ring of fire to decide who should
be the rightful king Arthur is defeated
pretty easily as he has never fought
under water whereas all has mastered the
art just before he is killed Arthur is
rescued by Mira and the two set out to
discover the Trident of Adlon Atlantis's
original king this trident will allow
the bearer to control all ocean life but
is hidden away with its location unknown
ohm tasks Manta who is still angry with
the death of his father were tracking
down and killing the two he grants him
Atlantean technology which Manta
upgrades and uses to assault Meera and
Arthur
however they apparently managed to kill
Manta and head out to the trench they
are attacked by the monsters that lived
there but managed to escape and make it
to the Earth's core this feels like it's
been ripped straight out of the Land
Before Time and the to discover that
atlanna is still alive and has been
living there all along Arthur gets the
Trident and returns to stop ohm and his
army before they can defeat the king of
the brine and combine their forces to
take on the surface world in what is the
best underwater battle I've ever seen
Arthur user2 tried in to control all of
Holmes forces and stops them defeating
all in the process Arthur is proclaimed
the king of Atlantis and spares his
brother's life after atlanna returns and
shows all that he is being misguided
Arthur will now bring the two worlds
together as one and bridge the gap
between the species saving the world
from destroying itself in the process in
the final scene of the film Tom walks to
the end of the pier to be finally
greeted by atlanna once more and the two
share a kiss symbolizing the bonding of
the two worlds in what is one of the
best final scenes in a comic book movie
since the Dark Knight Rises the
post-credits scene of Aquaman brings
back one of the film's main villains
Black Manta Manta has been rescued by
dr. Steven shin after falling tears
apparent death dr. Shin is obsessed with
finding Atlantis and Manta agrees to
take him there which beautifully sets up
a sequel those who are aware of shins
backstory in the comic books will know
that the doctor was a friend of Tom
curry Aquaman's father however it is
unclear exactly what direction the
cinematic universe will take the
character in in the comics he's pretty
much an ally to Aquaman but his
allegiance with Black Manta in the movie
makes it seem that he may be an
sorry Black Manta is of course one of
Aquaman's greatest films in the comic
books he's been in several teams
including the Suicide Squad though I
doubt that they will include him in the
movie version Aquaman accidentally
killed mantas father at one point and
this sent the villain on a crusade to
kill all of Aquaman's close friends and
family it's definitely in aesthetic that
I'd love to see them adopt in the films
and I hope that this is the way that the
rivalry goes between the two so what are
your thoughts on Aquaman did you enjoy
the film and what direction do you hope
that the DC movie universe will take now
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of the new
spider-man far from home trailer which
will be linked at the end of this video
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]